[Applause]
raise your right hands and repeat after
me
all right you solemnly swear
[Music]
now given in this record you are now in
the Navy for this post of duty you have
come from every walk of life you have
left important jobs and you have given
up other opportunities in your previous
experience you represent the best
examples of American womanhood
physically fit resourceful alert
intelligent and morally dependable you
are the American woman because you want
to live in the forefront of your times
in ideals and in sacrifice you have
elected this as your chance to serve
and you've chosen a woman size job the
purpose of your basic training is not to
lessen your individuality nor to change
the particular character of your talents
it is rather to provide you with
self-confidence and habits of living
that will raise your talents to the
highest peak of efficiency you the
modern woman are well equipped to set a
high standard of voluntary performance
you have a background of resourcefulness
and stamina derived from the democratic
culture of your age you have the skills
which can be adapted to your new
responsibilities now you will need to
raise your standards of physical health
to perfection and to keep yourself in
the best possible condition to perform
any Duty you may be give up you will
need to keep an eye open for any sign
that your efficiency is low and to seek
medical advice whenever you suspect that
you might not be quite all on the job
I find nothing wrong physically but I do
think you're suffering from fatigue and
working hard well yes sir
you see I wrote we all have a big job to
do but you've worked hard during your
basic training too didn't you you may
have felt tired but you weren't rundown
that's because you followed a regular
routine you had a good diet which
included plenty of energy giving foods
and lots of fresh vegetables and mil to
supply all the proteins and vitamins you
need you got regular hours of sleep then
plenty of exercise didn't you I had two
regulations you know
yes but the purpose of those regulations
was to set up habits that would keep you
in top-notch physical condition all the
time
if you break those habits you're going
to fall down on the job now I'm going to
give you a prescription and this is the
prescription the medical officer gave
her a balanced diet a normal regular
amount of sleep daily exercise and
relaxation these are all regular needs
which can never be made up if they are
lost to maintain top-notch working
efficiency the right balance must be
kept neglecting any one of these props
to efficiency is a sure way to physical
and mental fatigue fatigue and faulty
posture go hand-in-hand let's see why
here in simple diagram is the body
skeleton and some of the muscles which
hold it erect correct posture is correct
because it is natural easy and involved
no strain on the muscles a plumb line
dropped from the ears should pass
through the shoulder hip knee and ankle
joints
in incorrect posture the muscles are
under strained and have to work much
harder to hold the body erect a line
through the same joints is no longer
straight your internal organs are fitted
into closed but adequate space in
correct posture forces them into
unnatural positions so that it is hard
for them to do their work you will feel
better and look better too if you watch
your posture check it often and remember
to stand tall walk tall be conscious of
it it will be natural in a short time
sit tall you will feel and work better
you are proud of the fact that you're
healthier and stronger than the women of
25 years ago and your clothes are styled
for action your uniform is more
practical than the ones the yeoman Nets
had in the last war you can be glad of
that and you can be glad you don't have
to wear this armor plating pouring the
body into this unnatural shape congest
the internal organs and makes it
difficult even to stand naturally we
know today that girdles and closets are
supposed to support and protect the
figure many women don't really need them
but if you do wear a girdle it must be
right for you you should not tolerate a
girdle that fits improperly anymore than
you would wear old-fashioned clothing
too much tightness or downward pressure
of waist constrict the abdominal organs
and interferes with their normal
activity if a brassiere is required it
should not compress the breasts or push
them downward for those who really need
them well fitting girdles and brassieres
will support the figure and relieve
fatigue the correctly fitted girdle
lifts the abdomen and helps to flatten
the back another special reason for
fatigue is a poorly fitted shoe Nature
has provided you with cleverly
constructed flexible arches formed by
the bones and joints which constitute
the framework of the human foot every
time the foot is brought down this
framework absorbs the shock of contact
with the ground and supports your weight
but an incorrectly fitted shoe will
nullify all nature's good intentions a
shoe which is too small compresses the
foot
and prevent natural action it will in
time to form the foot if shoes are
fitted properly the inside edge will be
straight there will be about half the
breadth of the thumb between the tip of
the great toe and the end of the shoe
and plenty of width the shoe should not
be so wide that the arches spread or
that rubbing causes blisters the ball of
the foot should rest upon the seat which
is the widest part of the shoe the
leather of which your shoe is made
should be soft and pliable yet the shoe
itself should be reasonably heavy and
should have a welt sole to give the foot
protection a shoe with a lining and a
strong shank is the most comfortable for
drill selecting a shoe which is not
functional is hardly less than bad taste
but you can rely on the smartness of an
Oxford like this for ordinary wear it
supports the foot and has heels which
are appropriate to any activity except
long marches hiking or extensive field
duty for these purposes you need a shoe
which has a lower heel with a broader
base badly fitting stockings can cause
almost as much discomfort as badly
fitting shoes they ought to be about a
half inch longer than the foot to
prevent binding and a badly mended
stocking like this will soon produce a
blister stocking should be mended
carefully with a soft mending thread so
that they will not cause blisters this
expert method of weaving and
interweaving will give you a flat even
surface which will not irritate the skin
since your feet support your body all
day long they deserve special attention
here is a simple exercise to
lengthen them if they are weak flex the
toes as if you are picking up a marble
then in the same motion turn the toes
upward as if to show the marble to
someone this is an easy exercise which
should be repeated often if your feet
are tender and tired from unaccustomed
watching toughen them up by soaking them
in cold water to which salt has been
added
be careful to dry thoroughly between the
toes powder is helpful and it should be
used in the morning as well as after
bathing you are less likely to get
athlete's foot if the skin is dry
athlete's foot is an annoying and
uncomfortable disease it appears first
as patches of white skin between the
toes in advanced stages the skin itches
and becomes painful if you get it report
for medical treatment and be careful not
to give it to other since the fungus
which causes athlete's foot lives in the
moistness of showers pools and bathrooms
it is always wise to walk through the
chemical solution which is provided in
most places to kill the organism and to
wear slippers in these places
corns and calluses are caused by badly
fitting shoe to relieve the pain and
discomfort caused by them soak the feet
in silty water until the skin is soft
then file the corn with an emery board
if possible cutting or paring them out
is dangerous and may result an infection
a moleskin adhesive dressing or a bit of
lamb's wool or even wool yarn if the
corn is between the toes
will help to relieve the pressure and
the pain the only way to prevent corns
and calluses is to wear properly fitted
shoes choice of shoes girdles all
articles of clothing is only part of the
talent for good grooming to which every
wave aspires here is where patience and
resourcefulness count for a good
grooming is not guaranteed by the fact
that you happen to possess a smartly
tailored uniform it demands constant
attention to little details sending your
uniforms to the cleaners often or
sponging and pressing them regularly
yourself
it means shining your shoes every day
keeping your under clothes clean even if
laundering facilities are limited and by
no means least good grooming calls for
strict attention to bodily cleanliness
during your daily bath you will need to
wash every part of your body thoroughly
the superstition which still crops up
occasionally in spite of modern
education in cleanliness that intimate
parts of the body should never be
touched even in washing is as ridiculous
as it is old-fashioned soap and water
are needed all over the body ordinary
soap and water cleanliness will also get
rid of normal body odors though you may
want to use a mild underarm deodorant to
neutralize perspiration odor be careful
to use only
one which is non irritating to your skin
there are however artificial odors which
arise from disorders in the mouth or
vagina and which though unnoticeable to
yield may be very unpleasant to others
don't hesitate to ask your friends if
you suspect such a condition if they are
really kind they will tell you just as
you should tell them so that you can
have the condition checked by your
medical officer simple medical treatment
will often cure even a deep-seated
condition of this sort then you will
want to take good care of your
complexion a healthy skin is acquired
through the ordinary routine of diet
sleep and exercise and is easily
preserved by the use of plenty of soap
and water a little cold cream or mineral
oil at night is a good habit care and
applying your cosmetics only to a clean
skin with a clean powder puff is another
these simple methods will keep your face
as fresh and attractive as the most
elaborate beauty treatments a stiff nail
brush soap and water a cuticle stick to
clean around and under the nails and
plenty of vigorous scrubbing will keep
your hands soft it would also keep the
cuticle pliable so that it can be pushed
back with a towel a little cold cream or
mineral oil at night now and then and
regular attention to filing your nails
will keep your hands attractive even if
you should go for months without a
professional manicure
daily vigorous brushing with a brush
that has long stiff bristles will add
life and luster to your hair and here
are some hints about giving yourself
that shampoo you will need every week or
two depending upon the oddness of your
hair and the conditions in which you
live if you are hair and scalp or dry
use a small amount of oil the night
before you wash it too much oil however
will make the hair greasy and will be
difficult to remove any excess should be
rubbed off with a towel there are
several commercial preparations on the
market known as winning agents which are
frequently more efficient than soap if
soap is used don't rub it directly on
the hair make it into a solution work
the Lava well into your hair rubbing the
scalp with your fingertips and rinse it
thoroughly and did your hair squeaks
when you rub your hands over it
wash your hair several times before the
final rinsing don't forget that you are
responsible for leading the wash Bowl
and the shower drain clean and ready for
the next person who wants to use it a
shower if available is the best method
for rinsing your hair
at any rate be sure you have removed all
the soap remove as much water as you can
with a towel and while your hair is
drying is a good time to clean your comb
and brush a little ammonia added to
plain water is a good cleaning agent
follow this with soap and water
keep your Coleman brush clean and allow
no one else to use them if you are
clever at such things combing the hair
when it is partially dry and setting it
will produce much the same effect as the
hairdresser's finger wave remember that
clean hair will help protect you against
unsightly skin and scalp infection there
are a number of different skin disorders
which produce rashes dandruff may be
accompanied by an extensive one some
come from an allergy some may result
partly from a poor diet and lack of
exercise the oily skin is characteristic
of acne some such as impetigo may be
contracted by exchanging toilet articles
and some may be caused by syphilis all
of these skin disorders no matter what
the cause call for medical attention it
is possible that under difficult
conditions which arise in wartime you
may come into contact with some form of
lights rather than being horrified an
intelligent woman will seek medical
advice in such a situation if such
advice is not available you might employ
an old remedy to get rid of lice on the
head with the hair thoroughly with equal
parts of kerosene and vinegar
cover the hair with a towel for a half
hour
then wash with warm water and soap or a
wetting agent this process should be
repeated after eight days and again
after eight more days have elapsed so
that all lice hatching from remaining
eggs will be killed there are other
kinds of lice which are acquired from
close association with persons who are
infested these are called body lights
some are very dangerous because they may
carry typhus or other fevers crab lice
may be caught from toilet seats or from
intimate contact with the body of a
person who has them if you find them in
the hair on any part of the body medical
attention should be sought some of these
instructions for good grooming may be
old stuff to you but they bear repeating
because they are essential to
cleanliness and cleanliness is the basis
of all good looks
no woman who really cares about her
appearance or her health will neglect
the matter of internal cleanliness which
begins with the mouth we hardly need to
be told to brush our teeth at least
twice a day but a few hints about proper
methods may be helpful your toothbrush
should have bristles of different
lengths which are set in Tufts rather
widely spaced it should be kept clean
and dry in fact using two toothbrushes
ultimately is a good idea the best way
to keep your teeth clean is to brush
them with an up and down motion this
motion also massages the gums
additional massaging of your gums in
this manner will help to avoid pyuria
rinse thoroughly after brushing since it
is impossible to clean between your
teeth with a toothbrush dental floss
should be used frequently
the purpose of visiting the dentist at
least twice a year is to check and
control decay prevent Tata from
collecting and make sure the teeth and
gums are healthy constipation is a
rather common condition but the
cathartic habit or the enema habit in
fact even the fear of constipation
frequently has worse results than
constipation itself let the medical
officer advise laxatives if they are
really needed first you ought to have a
regular time for going to the toilet
in group living such as yours it may be
difficult but try and choose a time when
you won't have to hurry to make way for
others when you can relax for a few
minutes by the way dude ain't much water
not very much I'm afraid
well drinking lots of water is important
and be sure you eat a balanced diet with
plenty of leafy vegetables and whole
grain cereals then remember that the
regularity with which your bowels
function depends on your general body
tone sleep and exercise are important do
I have to have a bowel movement every
day not necessarily though most people
normally do the interval between
movements may vary considerably from
person to person but if the movements
take place regularly and you feel well
it doesn't matter
constipation if chronic may cause a
common disorder known as piles or
hemorrhoids the intestines empty their
contents into the rectum which acts as a
reservoir the rectum is well supplied
with blood vessels here in a
diagrammatic section through the rectum
we can see how hemorrhoids occur
repeated straining and emptying the
bowel forces the blood vessels at the
anus and sometimes part of the intestine
itself down from their normal place
until they protrude they are usually
quite sore and often bleed preventing
constant
nation helps to avoid them but if
present hemorrhoid should always receive
prompt medical attention as a part of
your physical examination
the medical officer checks the condition
of the pelvic cavity where the organs of
reproduction are located an intelligent
woman will realize that this is just as
important as a regular dental
examination or a check on her blood
pressure for reassurance that no
structural difficulty or acquired
infection can interfere with the normal
functioning of the body is conducive to
well-being and she will welcome the
opportunity which the Navy provides to
have this examination made by a
competent medical officer an intelligent
woman will realize also that it is not
enough for the physician to know that
her physical condition is good she too
must understand the structure and
function of all parts of her body
unfortunately however ignorance about
the reproductive system is still
widespread no human process has been the
subject of more superstition and fear
and consequently the cause of more
sorrow therefore you will want to know
the truth about every part of your own
body
a woman's reproductive or sex organs are
peculiarly adapted to the functions of
childbearing here they are seen as they
would appear if the body were
transparent the main organs form a
series of hollow or tube like passages
the external parts of the reproductive
organs consists essentially of several
folds of skin called the labia or lips
and known as the vulva these folds of
tissue cover important structures one is
the urethra from which urine is passed
another is the clitoris a small body
analogous to the male penis here are the
openings of two small glands which
provide a lubricating fluid called
mucous covering more or less the
entrance to the internal organs is a
membrane known as the hymen or
Maidenhead although the hymen is present
in most instances some girls are born
without it it is often broken during
childhood the superstition that a woman
is not a virgin unless she has an
unbroken hymen is completely inaccurate
for proper orientation let's look at the
body from the front view again the
reproductive organs can be seen in
normal position in the pelvic cavity
let's split the model and turn it to
observe a section through the middle of
these organs here we can pick up where
we left off on the external organs the
hymen as we have said stretches partly
over the entrance to the internal
reproductive organs the first of these
is a channel like structure called the
vagina which served as a receptacle for
the semen and forms a birth canal it has
a moist lining this membrane and its
walls lie in folds which can be easily
distended the cervix is located at the
inner end of the vagina forming the neck
of the uterus or womb the uterus is a
pear-shaped organ which is normally
about two and three-quarter inches in
length by one and three-quarter inches
in width since its purpose is to shelter
a baby during pregnancy the uterus is
capable of enlarging too many times its
original size in addition to the organs
of reproduction we see in this view the
bladder and the rectum here are the
reproductive organs in front view at the
upper end of the uterus are two tubes
one on each side
call the oviduct or fallopian tubes
their purpose is to transport the ovum
or egg from the ovary into the uterus
there are two ovaries each one located
near the end of a tube and it is in the
ovary is that the female reproductive
cells the OVA are form
when an egg is fully developed it leaves
the ovary and enters one of the
fallopian tubes this process is called
ovulation the egg is then transported
slowly toward the uterus so slowly that
it travels only a few inches in three or
four days during that time it softens
and begins to be absorbed unless it has
been fertilized by a male sperm on the
way
during this regular process the walls of
the uterus have been building up to
prepare for the nesting of the possible
fertilized egg then some time after
ovulation if fertilization has not
occurred
menstruation takes place this is a
regular cleaning process the thickened
membrane lining the walls of the uterus
breaks down and is cast off this broken
tissue together with the blood and mucus
which accompanies it forms the substance
of the menstrual discharge which passes
out through the vaginal opening there is
nothing mysterious or strange about it
the process is as natural as the peeling
and replacement of skin cells if the egg
has been fertilized by a male
reproductive cell or sperm it implants
itself in the lining of the wall of the
uterus
where it continues to grow add
menstruation usually stops when
fertilization does not occur the
processes of menstruation ovulation and
menstruation take place in a regular
cycle which recurs in most women
approximately every 28 days however your
schedule of this cycle may vary
considerably from this one furthermore
the cycle may be upset by changes in
bodily condition environment
mental stress or other causes
so that menstruation may be hastened or
delay
if your menstrual period should be
delayed as much as a week you should see
the medical officer immediately to
determine the cause never try to bring
on menstruation by any method for they
are all dangerous only the medical
officer can safely advise you the most
alarming thing is about menstruation are
the old wives tales concerning it what
we need is more frankness and less fear
I've been wanting to ask you sir why is
menstruation often so painful
menstruation shouldn't be painful pain
usually indicates that something is
wrong either with the position of the
reproductive organs or their functioning
I have some charts which will explain
better
yeah
and he explains that there are a number
of causes of menstrual pain or
dysmenorrhea if the uterus is not in
normal position there may be congestion
during menstruation and consequent pain
there may be other anatomical reasons
for dysmenorrhea or the cause may be
functional here for example you can see
that part of the intestine is near the
reproductive organs normally there is no
bad effect but constipation may cause
pressure on them and make it difficult
for them to function naturally as we
have seen earlier poor posture may crowd
the reproductive organs into unnatural
positions and cause congestion with
possible resultant pain actually no one
can diagnose the real cause of
dysmenorrhea without a thorough
examination what can be done about it
that depends on the cause extreme
malposition may call for an operation
actually if the cause is constipation
the remedy lies in its cure yes but when
you have cramps you want to relieve them
quickly
well then applications of heat a hot
water bottle for instance will often
help to relax the muscles and relieve
the pain and drugs such as aspirin will
give temporary relief most of the
pain-killing drugs sold for this purpose
are dangerous however and the habit of
depending on drugs is a bad one for any
severe menstrual pain you should have a
medical examination to determine the
cause although it is advisable to keep a
record of the menstrual period its onset
should produce very little change in
one's ordinary routine an intelligent
woman will not regard herself as ill on
the contrary though she may avoid
violent exercise she will find ordinary
accustomed forms of exercise good for
her
and we'll take pride in going about her
duties with our accustomed enthusiasm it
is especially important to keep yourself
attractive and clean during the
menstrual period since the danger of
offensive body odors is greater then
than at any other time regular bathing
is not harmful and is actually essential
to get rid of additional body odors
which are present it is only necessary
to see that the bath is not unusually
hot or unusually cold modern hygiene
offers two good methods of sanitary
protection the sanitary pad and the
tampon you are the best judge of their
relative value for you if sanitary pads
are used they should be kept clean and
should be adjusted carefully to prevent
irritation for this reason they should
be fastened to a sanitary belt which has
adjustable fasteners both sanitary pads
and under clothing should be changed
often and as an additional guard against
the presence of body odor it is wise to
use a good deodorant powder of course
selecting one which is not strong or
irritating it should also be used on the
under clothing
some women prefer the tampon to the
sanitary napkin the tampon is inserted
into the vagina to absorb the menstrual
flow if you use the tampon be careful to
see that it is placed far enough back in
the vagina to be comfortable but not far
enough to cause pressure on the cervix
for those women in whom the vaginal
opening is small for those who flow very
heavily the tampon is not usually
satisfactory some women use both a
sanitary pad and a tampon during the
days of heaviest flow many women find
the vaginal douche a necessary routine
but it is wise to have a medical
examination and to get instructions from
a physician before using one for the
first time while it is not common
practice to use a douche during
menstruation it is not harmful
the douching fluid can be plain warm
water or a solution of plain water plus
one tablespoon of baking soda or water
plus one half glass of vinegar depending
on your physicians instructions strong
solution should be avoided since they
injure the delicate lining of the vagina
a douche is best taken lying down in the
bathtub since the amount of pressure
depends on the height of the bag and
little pressure is needed place it so
that the bottom of the bag hangs about
six inches above the level of the hips
the douche may also be taken sitting on
the toilet check the height of the bag
carefully since excessive pressure if
the bag is too high may force the fluid
up into the uterus the nozzle should be
gently inserted and the labia held
lightly together with the hand so that
the badge '''l cavity will be slightly
distended as the water enters and the
fluid can flow freely out of the vagina
since the possibility of strong pressure
is greater many physicians feel that the
bulb or hand type spray should be
condemned others believe that it may be
used but only with the greatest care if
the hand type spray is used the bulb
should be pressed gently with the thumb
and index finger never with the hole
pressure of the hand equipment for
douching should be kept clean and
reserved strictly for your own use there
is great danger of infection if these
articles are exchanged
we have seen that there are glands
around the entrance to the vagina which
normally secrete mucus the amount of
this secretion varies with changes in
the menstrual cycle and increases under
sexual excitement but it is usually not
noticeable in color order or amount a
persistent vaginal discharge which is
noticeable on your under clothing is an
indication of some disorder which ought
to be investigated only a medical
examination of the individual who has it
and of the discharge itself will reveal
the cause and the proper treatment this
is a type of vaginal discharge or the
greater which is not too difficult to
clear with medical treatment well it's
good that you came to see me about it
early while cancer is not very common
among women of your age it is quite
dangerous when it does occur therefore
it's important to report any unusual
signs vaginal discharge lumps in the
breasts or any abnormal growth not
because they necessarily are cancer but
to give us a chance to diagnose them and
discover cancer if it is there in time
to cure it you know cancer is curable if
the treatment is thought at early enough
but you have nothing to worry about none
of you need worry about your health if
you rely on your medical officers and
remember the rules of personal hygiene
one important purpose of your basic
training is to make the fundamentals of
healthful living so automatic that no
physical disability will appear to
prevent you from carrying out the
important jobs you are here to do
perhaps you will be sent to a Naval Air
Station like this where thousands of
posts of Duty await women who are
dependable and well trained
perhaps you will be stationed at a naval
base but wherever you are you will have
a woman size job
keeping yourself in the best possible
physical condition for it need not be
difficult if you consider that the basis
of all good health is a balanced routine
of proper diet sleep exercise and
relaxation that high standards for
personal cleanliness will prevent most
disorders and the carelessness ignorance
superstition and fear are your worst
enemies if you remember these things you
will help to attain the goal of the
whole woman's reserve and keep every
woman at her post every day
[Music]
you